okay 2009 I was in South Africa in a
small village called Yuta and with other
Stanford GSB student including this lady
over there we wanted to understand the
education system in South Africa and
these children here they don't speak
English so we envision the world where
we provide English education to these
children to make them a member of the
global community there are 1.5 billion
English learners in the world and our
company robotium provides English
education with humanoids to 1.5 billion
English learners in the world so in my
presentation to you today I'd like to
first talk about the problem we are
addressing and the solution we are
offering and then I'd like you to join
the discussion in terms of where in the
world we should execute this business
whether it is in Asia u.s. or somewhere
else in the world so let me talk about
the problem forest when I was between 2
and 6 years old I was in Chicago this
was my house the White House and my
English was perfect native English
speaker pronunciation but then at the
age of 6 I went back to Japan my parent
wanted me to maintain my English
capability so I had two teachers and I
went to English classes three times a
week and one of these two teachers was a
native English speaker
she had excellent pronunciation
obviously and the other teacher was a
Japanese teacher and every time I met
with the English native speaker I
thought the class was extremely boring
because the class material was simply
uninteresting to me every time I met
with the Japanese speaker the class
materials was very engaging but she
begged me
please don't pick up my Japanese accent
for your English but a few years later
when I woke up in the morning I realized
that I had too much Japanese accent from
my English so so I knew from my
experience that human-based English
education is not perfect one teacher had
the problem to engage student the
material was uneasy and engaging the
other teacher was very engaging
but her pronunciation was poor and she
had a quality problem as a teacher I
took mini entrepreneurship classes at
Stanford and I learned that when I start
up a company I need to speak with
hundreds of potential users so that's
what I did I start incorporated and
spoke with about three people on average
for six months so 180 people as a sample
and and then really try to nail down the
problem and define it and so during this
process I realized that many Asian kids
actually have English input but they
didn't have opportunity to speak the
language I also realized that these
parents are really rich so they are
willing to spend tens of thousands of
dollars to give them opportunity to use
the language so I thought what if if I
spend all of our company resource to
this problem no English input but to
encourage children to speak the language
so that's the problem and here is the
solution we thought of a few weeks ago
you met with the Japanese company called
Cougar who provides virtual assistant so
what if virtual assistant teach English
for you the perfect pronunciation it can
it can be interactive you can speak with
virtual assistant by a voice recognition
technology but I spoke with men
many many users again and many of these
wealthy families did you want their kids
to use tablet addiction concern and
eyesight concern so I thought it is this
is not going to work it's also a little
bit passive tablet can be interactive
but it is not real we are trying to
encourage users to speak the language so
I thought something real is going to
encourage users to speak English more so
what about cheap robot I went on to
Alibaba and checked all of the robots on
Alibaba website and this one was the one
that voted by many kids as the cutest
robot and it's only $30 and it has all
of the capabilities that we need for
artificial intelligence execution that's
microphone speaker phone and camera so
he can do voice recognition natural
language processing and visual
recognition so I tried this solution
with many kids and it didn't work
kids were simply uninterested and not
engaged with this robot
so we tried many different robots and as
we tried different robots we realized
that when the robots are lifelike kids
were very interested so this is the
solution we came up with the robot with
up to 20 degrees of freedom with
lifelike movement strong CPU to realize
local artificial intelligence processing
and so I'll be happy to show you how the
kids are engaged with this robot so how
do I move this yes
[Music]
all right here I guess sorry
this kid looks like American but using
young man and this is English classical
[Music]
so in the video there was a scene where
we showed the social connection between
the robot and the children this is a
very important issue for education there
is an MIT professor called sherry Turkle
who studied the human robot social
connection I think for 15 years and she
concluded that human can develop social
connections to rabbit and you know the
social connection is really good for
English education we believe that as
there is a social connection established
it is easier for kids to be engaged in
English conversation with the rabbit and
we believe there some studies supporting
that that we are seeing so we talked
about the solution now I'd like to
invite you to a discussion in which
place in the world we should execute
this business so if we can I like to see
it gets to get some comments yeah so
yeah before getting comments I'd like to
explain some background information so
10% this is the US market 10% of all
public school students in the United
States are English language learners
this means English is not their primary
language and they're learning English in
the United States and 1% of all public
school teachers are English language
learner teachers that means there is a
huge discrepancy between supply and
demand 10 next discrepancy and there is
a new regulation that just implemented
called every student succeeds act so the
regulation is changing new government
grant is coming it's a great opportunity
in
the United States if you look at the
world the yellow country are the
countries with low English proficiency
here is the matrix here if you look at
China 400 million Chinese are learning
English Japanese are spending as
discussed often ten thousand dollars a
year budget for their kids English
education so as Korean so again it's a
great market just to summarize US market
five million users need to have English
education and a huge discrepancy between
demand and supply and Japan and Korea
families are spending big amount of
budget for English education and then
there is regulation change in Japan from
2020 virtually every college applicant
needs to take English speaking exam
China 400 million English learners there
is a Chinese company I think called VIP
kids who just waste 500 million dollars
what they are doing is to connect
American English speakers with Chinese
English learners by remote tool like a
virtual communication it's my
understanding so it's a great market so
can I get any your hey you presented
kids who are really low right like aged
2 3 & 4 right are you looking at a
particular target age group - or what
how do you want to do this yeah so lets
me let me explain this so our first
target age group is the age between two
and five years old there is a reason for
that we believe that the children at the
age between two and five years old can
absorb the language like sponge in
startup it's about payback period if it
takes long to prove the English
education
because he for our technology then you
know we are going to have a problem I
used to run the agriculture startup so I
learned from my heart that tomato takes
time to grow so we don't want to have
tomato like users we want to have past
learning learners which is which is that
age group including our ability so and
can I ask one other question what can
you tell us anything about the price
points so for instance are you gonna do
this as a service or are you just
selling the robots with software
installed how does that work we want to
start this as a service and this because
the first stage of the company is to get
learning going so if you sell the robot
and a very high price and people if the
people are not happy then we got bad
review on the website rather if we
provide this as a service if people are
not happy then we can simply stop the
service and then say thank you and can
you tell us any feedback and that's a
great learning so we want to start as a
service and we are when we are super
confident we want to start selling the
product okay so now that now the floor
is open
yes because English right turns a woman
to pay and I think their English level
right right right so the demand is high
and it's the huge number of people and
yeah
and obviously five hundred million
dollars you know raised by VIP kids is
no validation so thank you I have done a
few education startups and run them so
telling you from my experience in USA
especially because you're talking the
way to two to five and they're not
necessarily going to school full-time
that they are late what is it called not
kindergarten being one before
kindergarten to high school yeah yeah
and so as soon as they start doing that
and then they go to school they will not
have picked up completely they have
picked up half from my robot and if they
don't click with other things that could
affect you probably want to experiment
on robot human at the similarly age
group competition and so your concern is
that if they're interacting with the
robot instead of going to daycare
yeah right suppose they're interacting
with the robot in daycare yeah but what
is the advantage of doing that because
the daycare distance chart that's it
that's the purpose of the kid at that
age being able to observe the life and
we call it got natural that a robot
child so that is your to think about
very carefully and then you have to be
looking at only routinely choose those
families where English is not spoken by
their parents even in USA could be
Hispanic could be Latino could be
foreigners who come here from countries
where it's not spoken but have not seen
kids going through trouble just
I'm still not convinced that what other
kids or the environments will provide
will not be substituted yeah so if you
go to the US market I think it is going
to be the teacher aid for English
language learner in public schools these
schools have the regulation I mean what
do you want to do because when we were
trying to sell my other video game based
education company and so on in USA I
looked at different markets there are
all school districts are not identical
they're all different with they don't
control and so each of those schools
will tell you what is best about them
and you're taking the job of the teacher
aid would be charities did you manage it
English it was can I follow up and ask a
question the person at MIT or somebody
else who studied sort of child robot
interaction or human robot interaction
do they find that that does make
interaction with other humans is that a
negative factor for how people socialize
with other real people or does it have
an impact I didn't read that in the book
I read but but the author was negative
in terms of human robot social
connection because robot doesn't have
any heart so why do you want the human
to be connected to the robot was the
author's point you know so I understand
that point mm-hmm and I still believe
that for the education purpose this can
be leveraged but certainly kids have had
robotic toys forever I mean you know
this is this is old that's even before
we've had robots with AI so I think that
you know every since
ever since people have been putting
things together for kids to play with
they put together mechanical devices
that arguably would be kind of the same
sort of function that the the robot
would have absolutely yeah okay so what
do I have for other markets we've got
one for China we've got one person do I
hear yeah so so I think the question is
that in terms of the interpretation and
culture-wise
you know we're go to the market where
the AI adaptation is easiest right so
that's a that's a very interesting point
I haven't thought about that what we are
doing in terms of a little bit of the
artificial intelligence is that we are
gathering the user data user profile
data what kids like
and so and then incorporate that into
the conversation of that robot with the
kids so thinking about that each country
has a different culture right so for
instance Japanese kids may have
different food preference from Chinese
kids so we need to localize the content
so I haven't thought about what makes
more sense well but what
[Music]
right actually we are having Laura but
only speak in English right now and this
is because our first target user has
sufficient English input so we are
making the conversation content such
that easy enough for a user to
understand and that's the users learning
goes up or as we understand the user has
more knowledge we put more difficult
English words to the content but as we
all out we would need to have like like
Japanese Korean Chinese content so so I
understand that is coming so thank you
thank you for the advice
pretty good for a military kid there is
a very wealthy English musician just in
comparison to China China this epicycle
on a cracker
great point I haven't thought about that
you know if you look at this map in the
actual it's green you know not so high
English proficiency so thank you for
that we have a team of Indian writers
English writers in India so we will
consider that we have seen education
system which has and preschools the
pretty well-established
with one of the advanced English but
there are parents who are looking for
kids to come back home or to be at home
and learn more and they wanna they want
system which can help them out I did it
this is stupid
yes yeah a lot of parents who say okay
my kid yeah they would kindergarten they
learn English they're fine but one
they're bad they not be able to help
them out in the same standard as
kindergarten teachers would do
so they want some system at home also
which can help them out to keep that
that's a great point
parents so this depends on the parents
for our user base so one of the parents
I think the mother like the robot and
then and then the kids were very excited
about the robot and then father came
over the weekend and the father said
this is kind of noisy and the kid
started losing her interest so on the
other hand another user mother was
interested and kids got interested and
then the father came and then kids
showed - father how to use the robot and
the kids used English words in that
interaction with the father that she
never used so that amazed the father
that oh my daughter didn't speak this
English word but she is now guiding me
how to use the robot in English so so we
also observed that so so you have
besides making the video can you tell us
anything about how many kids you've had
try out the robot learning English and
are you charging money for this already
or is it really still at the stage of
kind of proof of concept oh it's still
proof of concept we are very early stage
so in fact some of the users that I'd be
happy to pay for that and I learned from
business school that you don't discount
the price for the Evangelist user but
you know I don't think we're there yet
to church the money to our users even
though they are willing to pay for it so
I'm violating the textbook principle and
not charging right now is the plan to
say put in content every month that
would be personalized to the user how
much will the robot store and
you've updated I mean could a kid can
potentially use this for years or yeah
so our goal is for for kids to use it
for years and then sure a subscription
of you that's the goal you would
download software into the robot every
so often right right every week is our
our goal and we are doing kind of that
right now
every week is kind of tough because
every time we release it there are needs
to be stabilisation tests before release
so stabilization test could take two
weeks so even if you do this in parallel
I still every week is a little bit tight
but we are doing that right now
yeah and can I ask what you're doing
with the data on the children's use and
you're collecting that right and
analyzing it I'm sure yeah yeah a little
bit so so every user we are talking with
right now it's very supportive when we
roll out this is something we need to be
very sensitive especially in the United
States there are many regulations that
for example we need to get exquisite
consent from the parents etc so and
before we before we go on what's your
feeling about advertising so reducing
the cost of the subscription in exchange
for right either giving data to
advertisers or putting ads into the
robots so I don't think it's a good idea
to put the ass to the robot because kids
can be very interested and influenced by
the ass so let's say the robot says hey
have you watched let's say I don't know
Disney such-and-such movie and and and
we could have a big trouble as a result
so okay
[Music]
we were not at that stage yet we're so
so the early stage of the software I
mean software company it's often to
approve the market risk first I think so
we are using some of the big companies
voice recognition system right now and
as we become bigger we are going to
develop our own voice recognition system
we have excellent software engineers
that I'm going to later introduce but
still you know if we develop voice
recognition system ourselves it will
take months and that could be a risk for
at a start-up so let me actually move on
to explain some additional color of the
market so when we think about humanoid
you know many of us think that's the
future maybe the timing is not there yet
but if you look at the market size it's
actually very large so on the right hand
side of this screen these are primarily
robots for Japanese market and we're
seeing half a billion dollars market
only by three companies and this is some
of the market projection from the data
points from these market research report
it's pretty consistent that is rising
very quickly
this is a news from a Japanese newspaper
called Yomiuri Shimbun so Japan had
introduced robots to classroom in public
schools and the budget I would imagine
is going to be increased over years and
if you look at this eyeball it was
introduced in 1999 and it was
until 2006 for a hundred fifty thousand
units and each eyeball was about two
thousand dollars it's 300 million
dollars sales for entertainment purpose
they introduced I bought till recently
and between January and July this year
seven month they sold 20,000 units and
every time they put here is reservation
they sold out within 30 minutes so it's
very good sales forty million dollars at
the minimum software so these are I
believe four primary like I bought was
for like entertainment I believe if you
look at Chinese market here are some of
the robot companies that we are
following so we have detailed data for
each of these robots and most of them
are for education purpose so Chinese
have started working on the robot and
they realized that the money is in
education so they do STEM education
English education and others so as a
Chinese market so we talked about the
market I also would like to discuss
we're in the word that makes sense to
execute the product strategy so here are
some options and again I'd like to
invite you for discussion if we have
time so one option is to fabricate in
China the second option is to do it in
Japan and the third option is licensing
and of course there are many other
options but for this slide I picked
these three so if he fabricated in China
obviously is the center of manufacturing
is low cost and the robot market is
rising and so it's easy to find hardware
partners I often went go to Shenzhen and
every time I go there I meet with you
know many hardware companies and most of
the time within one meeting
I have a I have a contract with Deb so
so very fast execution on the other hand
there is a trade war going on obviously
between US and China and it's hard to
know if the Chinese partners are using
authentic parts if not then we could get
trouble and they could steal potentially
the intellectual property unless we are
careful
so that's Chinese market I mean
fabrication there is an opportunity to
fabricate our product in Japan again it
was it used to be a twist the center of
manufacturing and as far as the robot
there is a big upside that Fukushima has
up to thirty million dollars grant for
robot innovation it's a huge upside it's
thirty million dollars per company and
this arising robot market and
manufacturing and intellectual property
is protected so that's Japanese market
and I forgot to say that we applied for
this grant and I'm very confident that
we are going to get the grant not thirty
million dollars but much similar amount
[Laughter]
so I worked for Fukushima in my previous
life we delivered robot to reactor
containment vessel inside Fukushima
nuclear power plant so I know a little
bit about Fukushima so licensing options
so we could license our technologies to
other hardware partners with for example
character rights transformer Star Wars
and everything and distribution channels
and marketing budget so which option is
do you think we should take
so you've got the hardware but you've
also gotten software is the idea that
you would have somebody make the
hardware and then you would take the
livery of the robot and then put the
software in somewhere else or what would
how would this work right now we only
have software okay that's what your
company has right and we could consider
purchasing some of the hardware
companies or hardware company yeah yeah
so important parts you do it in Japan
perhaps assembly them into it there with
it yeah I do number two I'm number three
so you need to do number - yeah - so the
licensing partners it works
he's how you do it he's my he's a real
proof of concept he's the best in class
and now you can apply to your normal
model like that is the licensing bigger
than nice to be bigger and easier right
another time okay I need to do it
yourself right yes Zoey - she's got a
brown I haven't got it but then okay you
know thank you for great advice that's
that's a great idea I think so any other
comments can't get that grunts just
might be quicker right by the company
right you'd be like microsites that
makes yeah right only do I believe D
Agostini I don't think it's Japanese
company they have Japanese subsidiary I
believe but these are like a soft Bank
or maybe it's hard to see from there
Softbank sharp and the Agostini is what
is written here for the humanoid
for for Sony they had a beautiful
humanoid called Korea which is unmatched
but I think they stopped selling it
abandoned the plan yeah they have they
have many different initiatives
and can i bowl or apple also right maybe
bitter in the u.s. to have picked
brothers on human noise right so this
does kind of leap to the question where
do you see your value okay is it the
holy system or is it the content the
English language and educational content
or is it the system for making the robot
really interact well I kind of thing
yeah I believe it's a comp it's
primarily content so so there is a I
believe a way to make a toy humanoid
very interesting to kids and I don't
think many have found how to do that
with the software and that's I view that
as content okay yes
if you could do a a childcare VA you
human with the robot can teach English
and normally in a childcare people of
similar ethnic background or need for
English to go there you could make it a
childcare traffic you know that you know
they go by so many hours and it's like
that becomes a social thing but multiple
kids of similar age coming to a good
duration time very innovative idea yeah
I have to really think you know it's a
great option right right yeah yes yeah
so that's a great point so many robot
companies have viewed that as an issue
so even you know the expert who are very
knowledgeable for pepper for example you
know they had a similar comment that you
know pepper could be $10,000 but what if
you know people get lost interest on the
robot so so in our observation we have
seen kids whose interest level continued
for nine month because we started in
February in terms of the development of
the robot and today is November's it's
about nine months so some of the key
it's continued to have interest some of
the kids one of the kids who was very
enthusiastic at the beginning and then
the she learned a few English words for
the first few days and then she lost
interest when the father said ah this is
noisy so so we see some variation right
now we believe it the key is is a few
things one is that we want to update the
content regularly in terms of the new
content coming it's like a movie right
you know if you watch movie every week
there is new content coming and you want
to know the story next week so your
interest level continued if you look at
the same movie again and again and again
then quickly use you would lose your
interest the second thing is the social
element social connection so for example
I don't know if you know Tamagotchi
or some of the social simulation game so
the MIT professor I first earlier in
this presentation sherry Turkle she she
studied Tamagotchi and all of the social
robots and there is a social connection
with robots and humans it seems to me
that the interest level could sustain so
if you think about that the way we are
doing it is that we get user data points
what are the kids favorite let's say
toys or food as a child used a robot the
robot remembers the user profile of the
user and and the robot is going to
include that in his next conversation
say Tomas feels like the character is
developing itself so every time he or
she uses it it's different
so it's unpredicted and
addictive and there is going to be a
social element because the way we
developed friends with others is to know
others so we think that's a key point
any other points with the toy market to
get back to your first question is the
toy market bigger in u.s. or other
educational games markets and what
happens if a competitor comes along Lego
Mindstorms ev3 robot that kids could
build and even code for their own
language learning in English or other
yeah how do you yeah that's a great
point so firstly I don't think we want
to target position ourselves a toy
company because toy I mean at least
initially right I mean the toy doesn't
have a high price except maybe mine
stored in terms of the intellectual
property issue I was supposed to show
that so maybe let me show that and then
if you still have questions we can
address that so this is some of the
factories in China again the rabbit
there are many many many robot companies
so with that you know I think somebody
commented you know what if you become
Microsoft for rabbit but there is an
important decision to make here too for
us to aspire to become Apple or rabbit
industry or Microsoft or Android for
rabbit industry as you know in early
1980s
there are many IBM clones and Microsoft
provided the software platform for all
of these IBM clones so that a software
can be executed on different hardware
if you look at the phone industry when I
was a college student in early 2000 I
had a smartphone by a Japanese company
we had a browser we had email and so
when iPhones introduced I was thinking
that well I had that when I was a
college student but all of these phones
died and if you look at the market today
Android is the market leader so if you
look at the robot market today there are
many robot companies and for all of
these hardware companies they make
software as well a twist-off
Deb so should we try to become Apple for
like competing with all of these
hardware companies or aspire to be
something like Android for robot
industry is the question to become the
Android of the rabbit industry it
requires special intellectual property
because each rabbit has different
degrees of freedom different weight
distribution different center of gravity
so if you have software to operate one
robot that may not work for another
robot it might let's say fall down so I
brought the robot to do a little bit of
the demonstration here to move to two
robots to see if it works
it's nothing up so this is a robot from
two different Chinese company this is a
robot by Chinese company called city
easy and this one is from a company
called link spot so let's see if we can
move them together so you're trying to
put one command that is being localized
into each operating system so yes it has
to be translated in on this two
different code right for the different
robots it's one software so yeah a good
sign
[Music]
have many other dance but for the
purpose of this presentation so so we
need to do something like this to become
Android for the robot industry so in
terms of the team whether it makes sense
to build the team in Asia u.s. or
somewhere else so before you go into
that what's your decision
do you want to be like Apple and compete
with your own hardware or do you want to
be the operating system that could might
work with multiple robots well so
million dollars question so yeah we can
have dinner together so but I think
right now we want to you know as he said
first to a little bit our thing and as
we prove it we are going to gradually
switch to a licensing type model because
if if people don't know if it really is
going to make money you know people are
not going to be interested for the
license so yeah I will go ahead and say
that that fits what we see in kind of
industry evolution that first you have
the into n solutions
you know the robot actually does the
English teaching and does the playing
and so forth and then as that becomes
really well established then you open up
the platform to young party developers
yes so where to build the team so I know
Bay Area and Silicon Valley is very
special place it's a special place
because you know you want to work with
best people right if you want to
proneural
you want to have best investor if your
investor you want to have
entrepreneur and best engineers so as a
result of this network effect Silicon
Valley becomes a very special place but
the question is whether it is too
expensive to live in Silicon Valley so
can we do something else as a start-up
I'm not talking about ecosystem as an
individual company we made a decision to
start outside of Silicon Valley so I
live in Irvine California Southern
California and I have a software
engineer from UC Irvine working with me
in Irvine office we have a team of
software engineers in Japan and Korea so
this man here used to be the head of
Internet division for NEC cooperation
with the giant giant Japanese
cooperation we have me move this way she
is a Stanford PhD with robotics and AI
Stanford AI researcher and the guy who
started humanoid software programming at
the age of ten and he won multiple
humanoid software competition and became
the judge for many competitions he was
vice president of that robot company I
said we we are doing much more exciting
why don't you work for us and he decided
to move to Japan work for us a search
engine engineer
we have many other engineers in our team
so and then he is our advisor he is in
Silicon Valley and he used to be
director of Apple for education research
so you know you could build the team
outside of Silicon Valley my belief so
in terms of investor where to raise
money this is an important choice and
again if you have any comments I'd love
to hear but if we go with Asian
investors the pros is that investment to
start up in Asia is growing in Japan
it's grew by 25 times for a corporate
with investment for startups or
five years that's a that's a huge growth
and then they understand English as a
pain but the here's the dilemma that if
he weighs too much amount of money in
Asia many US visas are going to see us
as a foreign deal so it's going to get
harder and harder to raise money in the
United States if we go to us investor
these are some of the most sophisticated
investor but they may not understand for
example Asian English education market
so there is important implication in
terms of the company direction so any
comments it may be may be so I you know
we are doing humanoid based English
educational yeah ii yeah so thank you
Scott Jesus yeah yeah like building a
custom house you gotta get go to I think
what you haven't got their party you
have okay these strategic who are in the
ante right right business yeah as you
can get more resonance there understand
it take than the average BC use looking
right price software yeah and then I'd
look at Gino's investors and the
investors in other robot companies are
not doing the same as you
yes more successful to market more have
more appetite yeah that's a great great
data bytes thank you any other comments
live I will do the same making few
people here and a lot of people outside
that you need some focus in terms of
business with me I'm not an investor but
you know you have to really start
talking to some just to learn how they
think to get focus and make a very
focused business plan so that but when
it comes to very vessels you want really
to get money from you you are well tuned
well focus if you have a time investment
is appropriately directed to a given
market or the business model and
household revenues back and we know all
that but no thank you thank you that's a
great comment you know a start-up is all
about focus focus focus right fine yeah
yeah absolutely that's a great comment
any other comments for this slide we are
key kids guy well you've got solutions
were like old it all little kids its
desktop didn't write these partners you
don't have a solution for the really
young kids funny just do stop the
license discussion and say here's a
solution just right yeah yeah yeah if I
can make a quick comment followed and
kind of in regard to your comment I want
everybody to realize how unusual it is
to have an entrepreneur who's willing to
put these questions out in front of
everybody because they're the questions
every entrepreneur has to go through and
usually you only hear the end result
where I believe a hundred percent that
we are right you know and we've made the
right decision so by saying this and
what the questions are a remarkable kind
of opening up to too much respect it
seems that it's all almost not the best
idea to go for that yet but to go
forward right since the deep roots
because they have resources
higher
cops investigation
so I don't know what people could hear
the the point was that how instead of
VIP kids because their parents can
probably afford human you know teachers
price sensitive markets maybe better and
getting out probably to the Asian
investors will get to the investors who
understand how those markets behave it's
a great point
yeah price sensitive
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah we are doing part of
that by talking with the government in
Fukushima so hopefully we are going to
get the grant when you talk about
developing countries the first thing
when government would concentrate it is
on the software development side rather
than the product side so they would
think more on the software and what
exactly is the use of that particularly
I mean is it really worth investing one
time and then they'll think about the
the software updated products and the
the market would same in their country
so the best you give it for the
mid-level market is what they think
about right right right
may not be that you know I just yeah
yeah right right
the vast majority of the people right
yeah even they decide they would think
about two different places on the
research or rnd the start of war you
were talking about we are still working
on that and the real-time service or
process of software development you know
two different yes
sector of PCs
right absolutely I'm curious what path
will take you quickest to getting
investment from the people sort of stock
markets so IPO is yes and if and then
all 200 countries potentially because
investors could make your company grow
if we got there and what it is it the AI
path is it having the dinner with
Professor Dasher around Android software
that will and Mac for language
processing in more than English you know
so you're teaching robots could be
teaching language in many countries um
and once that software natural language
processing teaching process is there and
then the investors will come to your
door but and maybe the wider people will
come to your door as well it's getting
the software down to get to the market
to the IPO right yeah yeah I mean I
believe it's the education efficacy that
we proved with the software it's the
first step to nail down
we are seeing some hints of that people
started speaking the words that they
didn't speak before and we want to prove
that more and right white paper and so
on and that's probably the first step
and then expand to other languages as
your points right so corporate license
yeah like you have a corporation who is
in the language training business and
they need the technology so therefore
you work with them they invest in your
company and they help you to open the
market at the same time so you do
everything for you and then do you have
a small portion of investment from there
a big enough for you and then later on
you have all the corporate partners all
over the world and you go IPO and you
make a lot of
okay
and of course parents want to spend this
can help those who are you know that
children or maybe adult for hitting for
college or maybe I'm already in the
business field for those who struggle
speaking English I know that Japanese
spent six plus years in school learning
English but absolutely no hope just
caring conversation when dirt and her in
college or in a company so what is it
like a future fall or Regent you do you
like to help those who struggle English
and help them to you know be able to use
with their business so that maybe
Japanese or Koreans are Chinese
what would is the vision I'd like to see
them yeah so I said you know I mean we
are starting with two to five years old
but the goal is to get two older kids
k12 is the next call I think kids based
on their observations kids up to the age
of 12 years old can be engaged with the
rabbit very much but I think we can go
higher older kids like 18 years old
etc and as you said you know I mean
coming from Japan and when I was young
Japan was very strong and it's my hope
to make my home country to open up its
economy to the world more right I mean
it's the same for Korea China India and
many other countries to become the
member of the global community this is a
very important issue especially for the
age of artificial intelligence I think
the world is going to be more and more
uncontrollable because we are already
seeing AI who only got the direction can
beat the human for chess game we can do
the same thing for many other things and
and if the future is increasingly
uncontrollable then we want to have the
society society adaptable and after all
to change and that's difficult when the
economy is closed and part of my vision
is to use the language education as a
way to open up the market for many
countries so actually that may be a good
kind of comment to close on did you have
closing comments Yohei or okay yeah
because that's a really good comment to
sort of end up the session today we've
got some refreshments outside like to
encourage everybody to continue to ask
the million dollar questions outside
we'll see how this plays out stay tuned
I have a feeling we'll see something one
interesting thing about this is instead
of looking at one thing I feel like I'm
looking at a pinball machine you've got
this market which will lead to this
market which will lead to this market
which as long as you find the right path
you'll do well with this so thanks very
much
[Applause]